okay well I'm coming from the Pacific
time zone so I won't force you to be all
awake and say hello to me my name is
Sarah kobilka and I too actually spent
most of my life in the informal science
education realm working at science
museums running camps really focusing on
that engage and inspire and the aha
moments and all that exciting stuff
until I transitioned recently into more
formal education role and actually just
finished a master's of science and
science education from the University of
Montana in Bozeman and it was an
opportunity for me to learn a little bit
more about the best practices of the
formal education realm and I think we
can take some of those best practices
and maybe they have a role for us to
play I know we like to think we informal
people got all the best stuff but I
would like to propose an idea called
backwards design and just by a show of
hands how many of you have heard of that
concept excellent okay so we've heard of
it for those who haven't heard of it
inspired by design by Grant Wiggins and
Jay McTighe is a wonderful book on that
topic it's a planning framework and on
the Vanderbilt website if you just do a
google search of backwards design you're
gonna find a video of Grant Wiggins
doing some teacher training and one of
the questions he says or one of the
statements he says is it's your job to
know where we want to end up and we just
said at the beginning how will I know
that this is successful and knowing what
the goal is is critical for designing
your program you have to think from that
backwards design
backwards position because there's a
disconnect from our short-term actions
and our long-term goals if we don't take
that backwards position so one thing
that teachers often get challenged on is
that they teach to the test that they
are focused on the content part and
especially before the next generation
science standards came in and gave us
the science and engineering practices
and the cross-cutting concepts those
content strands really were everything
and so the concept that was come up with
the backwards design is that you have
three steps
you start with your end-to-end desire
your goals then you figure out how do
you assess to see if you've met those
goals and not just what you're going to
take a test or a quiz on in a formal
classroom but what skills do you want
people to have what connections do you
want them to be able to make and then
finally they plan the learning
experience and instruction and in our
case in outreach we might come up with
this really great idea of the activity
that we're gonna do oh and then we have
to assess it and then maybe then I will
kind of think about what the goal was
and why we even did it and that that
disconnect just doesn't work so the
questions that you want to be thinking
about with your goals and questions I
don't have answers to but what do you
want your students to be able to do with
what they learn what meanings or
transfers do you want to make and when
we go from that meaning angle it puts
power in the students because it implies
that they already know something and
they can take what you're teaching them
and experiences that you're giving them
and take them and apply them to
something that already matters to them
and when we talk about those goals that
we want to set we use the acronym smart
so s is specific M is measurable there's
those metrics again a achievable
you're not going to eradicate hunger but
you can make an achievable goal with
regards to that you have are relevant to
the program that you're doing and T
time-bound you can't have a goal that's
just gonna continue going on forever
you've got a funder you've got a time
period or even just a program you still
want to have times with that so specific
measurable achievable relevant to the
program and time-bound now going back to
when you set those goals I asked you the
question of who's at the table when you
start that planning process oftentimes I
do we do some work at the stem Learning
Center with NSF funded programs and many
of you in this room have had people come
in and say okay my application is due in
one week can I can you write a letter of
support and you know help me out with my
broader impacts
because I really didn't think about it
but I got my whole research ready to go
so who is when can we get into that
conversation can we get in sooner who
else needs to be part of that
conversation when do you bring the
audience that you're trying to serve
into the conversation especially if
you're talking about some students who
are older if you're looking at working
with youth high school kids have a lot
to say and they know what they want they
know what they're passionate about they
know what will mean something to them so
can you bring them to the table at a
sooner at an earlier point we talked
about we had the concept of IRB just
brought up well do you bring education
researchers do you work with your
department with the College of Education
at your University or people who are
education researchers because there is a
difference between evaluating a program
and doing education research on a
program and so these people can bring in
some expertise and maybe answer some of
those questions that we might have
because that's not our area of expertise
when do you bring in those informal
science educators the people from the
museum from the zoo from the Boys and
Girls Club not oh we've got this whole
idea now we want to bring it to your
setting but hey come talk to us about
how we design something for your
settings so we don't make all these ID
or come up with all the ideas and then
we try to fit them into your setting so
things to think about as you're doing it
when you have those groups together and
talking from the very beginning another
bonus that comes out of it is you get
that shared vocabulary and having that
shared vocabulary then allows you to
have that communication on the topic
going forward and moving forward and
making it more of a sustainable not a
one-off thing but truly building that
relationship and connecting you with
those people in those audiences Karen
asks the question what data is worth
sharing I would ask this question what
data is worth collecting sometimes we
put a lot of time and effort into
collecting all this stuff because well I
think it might be useful but really we
have limited resources and we have to
acknowledge that so what is worth it for
us and for telling that story that was
mentioned we
the who the what the who the where the
what and the when those years sometimes
more metrics numerical things your
quantitative data but you need that
qualitative data as well to tell you the
how and the why I can tell you that we
increase from thirty to sixty percent
but how did it happen why did it happen
that's where that qualitative data comes
in in my personal feelings and so
connecting partners audiences education
researchers learning experiences to your
assessment which is tied to your goals
all this concept of connectedness if you
like talking about it well you are in
luck because the National Alliance for
broader impacts is coming to sunny
Tucson Arizona and that is going to be
happening April 30th through May 2nd and
connectedness is our theme so we have
good conversations going on here and
then you go through for most of you a
cold horrible winter and then you need
to get away from it all and work on your
tan so I am personally inviting each and
every one of you in this room to join us
for Nabi in Tucson Arizona and I will be
passing out these postcards so that you
can remember to join us for the fun to
talk about connections
you